faut que ça s'arrête ou pas du tout
michel vraiment une peur mais c'est
plutôt un stress qui n'a pas de plomber
quoi moi si l'émission s'arrête j'espère
que ça maintenir encore plusieurs années
mais si ça s'arrête
bon je me vois pas revenir journalisme
c'est vrai que maintenant j'ai changé de
vie s'ouvre est un peu de retravailler
toute la journée
et puis voilà je ne sais pas ce qu'on
pouvait me proposer d'autres excès et
puis il faut quand même vivre et c'est
donc pour ça moi aussi mettre de côté
aujourd'hui quand ça marche bien après
comme c'est un peu zappé une dépense un
peu on vous entend plus et venez pas
dangereux mais la hantise de la
déchéance mais déjà ça se passe la
retraite mais l'âge de mes l'âge de 6-7
ans à turin
j'avais lu l'histoire mais là de cette
lady hamilton qui a dû l'europe entre
ses cuisses et qui est morte née à vinay
à paris on me donnait des coups de pied
dans le ventre je me suis dit mais
jamais ça donc j'ai toujours adoré les
histoires de prostituées qui se range
qui épousent des bourgeois je me suis
dit ça y est elle à l'abri celle là
toujours toujours voté - battu mais vous
êtes dans le cas du cinéma et des murphy
avait raconté qu'ils étaient payés 25
mille dollars par film et après deux
échecs consécutifs il était passé à 5
millions je sais que pour les acteurs
comme voilà comme ça reste très
compliqué lâche pas je vous ne faites
que des succès mais ça ou deux échecs
des attaques hôtels et sans moi depuis
le génie c'est une pierre très chaud 25
millions ou païens cours de jeu ses
retombées donc mathieu et moi pour le
coup et depuis le début et depuis le
début de l' agent jean et qu'on ai marre
que les faux gel et ping et il ya un
monsieur qui passe et il me dit tu vois
ce garçon là il ya dix ans à son contrat
était surtout les directeurs de
programmes de deschênes 2 française qui
je vais vous dire qui mais se tassent à
la comédienne pardon un animateur réunit
sept animateurs la ya dix ans
tous les directeurs de programme avait
son ca sa photo sur leur bureau
tellement il était à la mode c'est
aujourd'hui le mec nous raconter qu'il
allait faire des anniversaires pour
vivre et ce jour là j'ai compris que
l'antenne c'était tellement tellement
dangereux dès que j'ai gagné un euro je
l'investis pour justement me dire si en
plus je suis viré mais au delà de
l'argent est ce que vous avez peur que
ça s'arrête pas là de l'argent bien
évidemment évidemment du son ça va
s'arrêter mais bien sûr que ça c'est
très très dur je pense que tous les
émetteurs ddm chose je m'en fous il ya
une vie après la télé sauf que quand ça
s'arrête sur nous fuit
rouge alcoolique beaucoup de choses
c'est sur 8 mai c'est horrible vraiment
toi je m'en fous que ça s'arrête mais se
savent pas comment c'est donc je suis là
dessus le seul truc moi qui m'inquiète
c'est vraiment cette obsession quand je
vois ce qui se passe dans la rue avec
des gens qu'on bosse et 40 ans et qui se
retrouvent avec mille balles doha le
seul truc qui m'obsède c'est de me dire
comment profiter de ça pour essayer
d'arriver à la retraite en ayant payé et
quelque chose à un appartement ou une
maison parce que c'est ça le problème il
est là c'est que les loyers sont devenus
complètement dingue et les gens qui
souffrent aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils
ont 8 109 s'emballe de noailles et donc
ne pas y arriver comme ça